[hopeful mumbling]
The fantasy cast lists have been posted.
Wow, so I guess I’m WR1 on the first team?
Oh, I'm gonna break some legs.
CMC’s the lead on the third best team?
But what if he get hurt?
That's how you all sound.
A freshman got a better part than me?
Wow. Can’t wait to see my name in lights!
BIJAN ROBINSON!
Say mister, do you know where I can find the big time?
Listen, kid.
They call it fantasy for a reason.
W-wait, I’m sorry. I’m Brandon Aiyuk’s understudy?
Don't be mad. But I got to miss, like,
the first couple of shows.
The young backs only got cast ahead of us because they’re cheap.
JT, it's not fair.
He's on vocal rest.
UGH..... receivers.
How now AJ Brown cow?
CeeDee Lamb got in a knee deep jam on a needy scam.
Calvin, you're a high upside Receiver 2! Congrats!
Bet! I mean NOT BET.
Let’s see...
Hey! There I am!
I barely even auditioned!
Maybe I should transfer.
Got another show! This is by the guy who always drafts a QB too early.
Wow, I'm the lead!
And my supporting cast is... two kickers?
Can they catch?
This show was cast by someone who hasn't
been following football in a few years.
Yes!
And this last one is selected by someone who thinks they are a fantasy genius.
Who's Sam LaPorta?
-Um, you are.
-Oh!
Time for the first rehearsal!
I hope everyone’s patient with me!
Uh, uh... LINE?
COME ON, THIS IS WHY YOU GOTTA COME TO REHEARSAL.
You should have f--ing picked me.
Hill Thrills Due Tua a Killer Script and Natural Talent!
BEARS REFUSE TO PERFORM, JORDAN LOVE PUTS ON A SHOW FOR CHICAGO FANS
AND HOLY S---, THE GIANTS LOOK F--ING ROUGH